who's your top five if you're so you
know you give your top five when the
conversation comes up you know in every
sport there's that combo who do you put
as an all-time great and by the way not
by weight class just go go oh
i would say john jones number one i'll
say uh
um
habibi got to go to number two okay i
would say uh
gsp
you better you put it above
yeah
and then i'll say um camaro usman four
and i'll say anderson silva you put
silver fifth yeah there was a time also
silva was vicious just nasty when he
would fight
yeah i mean these are guys that i like
to fight i mean i love i love the way
habit fight you know and i think that
you know um
gsp is amazing too gsp has been my
training partner for years and just
absolutely amazing when it comes to
fighting his fight iq is just on another
level who's he missing pat there's
someone on your top 500. you know i
listen this is his world
you just watch this gerard i do listen
the average person may who doesn't know
the sport technically is going to say
obviously how about conor mcgregor not
being the top five uh but but to put
those names
these guys went on a streak all of those
guys went on a streak of 20 matches
maybe i'm mistaken i think it's all of
them have gone 20 plus undefeated right
yeah obviously jon jones the only losses
the one that he
had no clue what was going on he started
elbowing on the guy number two you said
khabib who's what thirty twenty eight an
hour or two i don't know it's 29 29 i
know okay so that's that guy
three you put gsp who he went on a
rampage for a while
four you said usman who right now is
undefeated isn't it
how many how many matches has he what is
a usman's record today i couldn't even
tell he's 19. 19-0 pull it up so yeah i
mean
usman is usman and then you got five
being silva silva who went for a while
as well so give an honorable mention
yeah who who's not on the list
he's very very he's very company biased
here he's got nobody from pride fader
doesn't get any any love man we got we
got nothing for uh for any of the
gracies we got nothing i mean i mean i'm
thinking about you know you guys want
his friends to get mad at me i can say
you know i can say i can say an
honorable mention i can say fedor is
definitely in it i forgot all about
federer see i forgot about fedor man i
forgot about fatal fate fedor it can
definitely be in the top five that's
gotta be
dana white's biggest mistake right that
that that's got to be his biggest regret
you figured yeah i mean fatal not
getting them
over a t-shirt
tell the story well well the story as i
understand it is vader has his own uh
his own clothing line and he wanted to
promote his own clothing line when he
came to the tyler pull up this guy
uh and dana said
dana has a reebok deal you gotta wear
reebok
and that's that's
[Music]
they can never come together on on the
uh on the sponsorship i wonder
i wonder if it's the sport now but fedor
man fedor 20 years ago i mean
the fight on him and randall you can
watch that on repeat and you'll never
get tired of it
i mean yeah some of the old school guys
too and then the rules were so different
you guys had to fight five times in a
night you can get five times in a night
grand priest let me ask a different
question let me ask a different question
so we just right now said fight fighters
right and you put you know jon jones
khabib gsp usman and at the bottom silva
top five
greatest promoters
who were also good fighters we don't
even need to talk about number one it's
really who number two is because number
one is obviously yeah do you put anybody
above him muhammad ali no no no i'm
talking saying connor they're working in
their world do you put anybody hit a
counter as a greatest promoter who was a
fighter talk [ __ ] [ __ ] talker
you know um troll all of that nobody's
greater than connor i would say
uh number two will be uh chael sonnen
okay
number two
uh let's see what will be number three
um
the diaz
brothers ah man yeah they they're very
good at selling i mean but they don't
even they don't even mean to sell it
they just themselves unapologetic
unapologetically
yeah so you put them three both of them
i would say so yeah i mean those guys
those guys can sell a fight i mean
uh let's see who else is on there you
think kobe is a good promoter colby kobe
covington is a great promoter he's a
good promoter who who else are we
missing a name like i'm trying to
see he said anderson silva this is what
i always loved about the spider the
spider barely spoke english but he was
such a performer inside the ring
he was dude he was promoting his next
fight while he was beating the opponent
like he was you know and you know until
uh what's his name from long island
caught him uh
like that's what you were saying you do
it for so long you do it for so long and
all it takes is well chris weidman
one time yeah wait a minute on this
story with son and then i want to go to
yours is the press conference with sonan
and uh in uh uh
uh in uh silva where he says look all
you guys are talking about english look
if i go to brazil there's an app to
learn how to speak brazilian this guy is
not traveling here from brazil he lives
in vegas and he flies to he lives in
beverly hills and he flies to vegas i'm
traveling all the way you should feel
sorry for me not for this guy
he was a great smack talker
he brought it he was phenomenal man i
mean he he would practice his lines and
he would just get it down to the point
where i mean he was just so fluid with
it you know and he just you know he
unlocked his talent i think he's one of
the big reasons to help you know kobe
covington kind of come into his own and
just you know be the phenomenal promoter
kobe is i mean kobe is
kobe's up there you know kobe's really
good kobe says some stuff that
you know he's kind of funny you know
what i'm saying he's kind of funny to
things that he says and i think that
i think that's what that's what it has
to be you know you have to you know be
quick with it but at the same time kind
of funny at the same time the fighting
world needs a heal for sure yeah for
sure who's kobe fighting coming up
who's favorite in that kobe for sure for
sure for sure you you said something
very interesting you said practices
lines are you telling me that dana and
the ufc are having guys uh they're
giving guys some help with what they
should say and
leading up to the fights nah these guys
these guys do it on their own it's 100
organic 100 the beef is 100 percent
again
it's not you know mayweather and
mcgregor talking smack to each other and
then going back and into the room after
the press isn't there i mean like good
one old chap
uh
it's when the beef is because with mma
we still have that like that bushido
code you know where we just kind of like
honor respect and then when somebody
disrespects you
it it cuts at a different level you know
so you can't just shake it off and it's
not like nah we're not friends until i
punch you in the face you know
and then after you're not friends until
i punch you yeah and then after we punch
each other in the face a few times
we are not friends
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]